il y avait sept cafés à la ferrière du
temps où l'on exploiter une mine de fer
aujourd'hui plus aucun commerce pour le
maire il fallait retrouver du lien
social et faire de l'un des plus petits
villages du département une mine de
fleurs objectif l'an fleurissement de la
commune
oui mais le fleurissement participatif
donc c'est pas que la commune qui fait
ça c'est pas que la mairie c'est les
habitants qui d'ailleurs ont créé un
collectif qui s'appelle embellissons
autres communes est en fait les gens
jouent le jeu et ça nous créé à ce qu'on
appelle maintenant le lien social qui
est quelque chose de très important
parce que les gens sortent ils discutent
entre s'échangent des fleurs et puis sa
part voilà c'est très convivial
collectif et municipalité depuis
plusieurs années s'attache à créer des
lieux fleurit particulièrement dans les
espaces publics mais aussi devant les
maisons en y plaçant des bacs pour
planter et chacun ou presque
mais la main à la terre tous les
participants contribuent à comme ils
peuvent effectivement à leur échelle
donc ça peut être une petite
contribution financière s'est donné un
plan c l ai passé une demi-heure pour
refaire un désherbage c'est vraiment
chacun contribue comme il peut
quand il peut un choix de fleurs adapter
au changement climatique des plantes
simple de jardin orchestrée par des
passionnés comme dany la reine de la
bouture j'aime faire des boutures de
rosiers desrosiers de mon arrière grand
mère
c'est vers alger rouzier 1re séance hier
qui est une existe pratiquement plus
qu'il n'est pas remontant mais quelle
jolie donc je fais des boutures et je
peux en donner à tout le monde
bon cette année la canicule n'a pas
favorisé les choses mais alain ferrière
on ne lâche rien car derrière tout cela
il y à rêves obtenir une première fleur
dans la compétition des villages fleuris
si nous l'obtenons un jour elle sera à
l'entrée aux panneaux de la commune et
ça sera votre gère t ah oui oui